hello people welcome to the Reuben
report year end spectacular we are here
in The Young Turks Studio at The Young
Turks desk and I've brought with you a
very special panel for our year end
spectacular it's the COO of The Young
Turks himself Steve O coo and your last
name's o I'm honored to be here this is
your debut it took us a year to get you
on the show well I've been trying to get
on this show for a long time and I know
some people who work on the show pull
some strings and they got me on we uh we
heard questionable things about your
reputation so we wanted to wait till it
was the end of the year yes and then
we'll see what happens and a uh a
veteran of the Reuben report and the can
I call you the in-house Young Turks
comedian sure yes thank you very much I
like that moniker Mr Jimmy door the
in-house the inh housee it's better than
being the out housee you you could be
that guy too comedian I'll tell you that
all right so we are going to cover what
I think are the the biggest stories of
the year and uh we're going to start
with the NSA cuz that certainly I think
was the biggest one and and definitely
the biggest one at least around these
parts that we uh that we walk around in
uh so let's start with what I think is
the clip of the year and I'm calling
this the LIE of the year although a lot
of people are talking about the
Obamacare if you like it you can keep it
thing which we're going to get to this
is James Clapper uh the director of the
NSA he was at the uh Senate uh what was
it the not Foreign Relations the armed
services committee uh hearing on the NSA
and he gave us a Whopper
what I wanted to see is if you could
give me a yes or no answer to the
question does the NSA collect any type
of data at all on millions or hundreds
of millions of
Americans no
sir it does
not not
wittingly there are cases where they
could in inadvertently perhaps uh
collect but not not wittingly all right
all right so we we've talked about this
many times you know that's right out of
Seinfeld when you're lying the higher up
on your head that you touch that means
it's a bigger lie and he pretty much
nailed that one right there we now know
this is 100% lie uh he was uh under oath
right there when he did that um is this
the biggest lie of the year for sure
that's got to be the biggest lie of the
year right well I think of course it's
the biggest lie because you saw how hard
he was punished right after he said that
right right after he said that they
immediately gave him a raise and they
gave him a promotion so now he's in
charge I don't know what his exact
position is but he's in charge of
everybody again well he's doing he's
like running the committee that's going
to review the whole problem in the first
place after he lied about it the guy all
he did was Lie to Congress what's the
big deal but they but they blame Senator
Ron weiden for that they say that's his
fault because he shouldn't have asked
that question he that guy's not supposed
to be yeah so that's what that's how he
got around lying to Congress Steve do
you have any sympathy for a guy that was
asked a question that maybe he shouldn't
have been asked I'm being slightly
sarcastic obviously I'm outraged by this
story in fact I'm so outraged I can't
make any jokes about it because it's
it's ridiculous so um James Clapper uh
head of the NSA was formerly an
executive at Booze Allen Hamilton yeah
and now um and what what do they do they
have a no bid contract to provide data
mining services for the NSA what a crazy
Co an amazing and happy coincidence for
all involved so when the story first
broke I said immediately to Jen um I bet
you any amount of money that this is not
really about our security or even or
even about spying on Americans this is
really about money someone's making a
lot of money off of this and I I
guarantee that's why this is happening
and very quickly we found out yes it's
all about Boo Allen Hamilton so uh so
Clapper is now um you know head of the
NSA and he and he was a former executive
at at boo Allen
boo Allen's current executive was a
former NSA guy so it's a revolving door
and and and for these guys to say yes
possibly probably unwittingly I don't
know maybe I mean come on I mean it
makes a mockery of the whole system and
if you can get away with these lies that
impact all Americans essentially then
it's hard to take government seriously
it's hard to take the rule of law
seriously and it it just breeds contempt
for the whole process yeah so I want to
talk about the the bigger part of that
that you're getting to but just lastly
with the LIE itself why are there no
repercussions if you were to lie under
oath in a murder trial you know what I
mean there are repercussions why are
these people held with total impunity
because he's lying in the protection of
power he's not he's not lying when he's
trying to screw over power he's lying to
protect them so they all go oh he's he's
helping he's helping us so it's okay and
uh it's okay okay if you lie and you're
on our side that's basically it and uh
but if you lie about come on a dress or
getting a blow job in a hallway of the
Oval Office we're going to have to
impeach you but if you lie about
actually the most subverting the
Constitution and then that's okay yeah
so speaking to the bigger issues that
you mentioned there has Obama sort of
been uh let off the hook with this thing
because it seems like this whole thing
has happened it's happened obviously it
started under George W bush but it's
happened on Obama's watch too and nobody
really Associates him with that cuz you
have all these clowns like Clapper that
make such ridiculous statements that to
be honest I don't know and you know um
I'm a harsh Obama critic but on this yes
I wish I I wish he were more of a leader
I wish he would take the position hey um
not on my watch we're not going to have
this we're not going to violate the
constitution uh we're not going to waste
taxpayer money we're going to do the
right thing but to be honest I don't
think any president to be honest is
really in charge of this whole apparatus
that's been you know built over Decades
of National Security and defense because
God forbid if anything happened all
fingers point to Obama say you know what
Obama because you stopped as spying on
Americans now we have we have this
Terror strike so blood is on your hands
right but doesn't that show a huge flaw
in our system that I I totally agree
with you the president I don't know how
much he knew or how much he doesn't know
or how much they let him be privy to
purposely because they don't want it
getting all the way up to him so he
can't get in trouble but doesn't that
show a flow on the system if the
president himself can't control these
types of things well I don't you know I
don't know whether he can or the flaw in
the system is that everybody goes along
I think that's the flaw in the system
including the media seem to go along
unless it directly affects them then
they get pissed off they get really
pissed about hey you're tapping our
phone what the but if you tap
everyone's phone well
then so nobody really cares about that
stuff so is there a flaw in the system I
think there's a flaw in the overall
system that the people who are the
watchdogs for our society are now
co-opted by the people they're supposed
to be watching and so that's why things
like this happen that's why you can uh
cut food stamps at the same time if
you're giving doctors raises in the same
bill right so uh that we we need a
watchdog and that's why we're here don't
forget corn subsidies I love the that's
my big one and the thing too the reason
why I don't blame Obama even more than I
I want to blame BL him on this NSA U
issue is that there is no real public
outrage either it's only the far right
and the far left or upset the vast
majority of people seem to be like ah
whatever privacy shivy whatever we don't
care uh there's no outcry from the media
because you need to have all of that to
empower the president to put a stop to
something that's been going on for so
long he can't just do it on his own
because he could be wrong he's not and
this President is not the leader that's
going to that's going to make that kind
of bold that this is not step this is
not him he's a consensus Builder he's a
he's a bureaucrat in many ways and and
he's not going to be that guy who says
we're going to go in my direction and
pull everyone my in my way he's not that
guy yeah and without the outrage just
won't happen so final thought on this so
obviously we have to bring up Edward
Snowden um what should happen to him now
because that seems to be the debate now
is you know is he going to stay in
Russia forever is he going to maybe make
it to Brazil we have all these fools I
think like Diane Feinstein saying she
you know he should come back here and
and face whatever uh face the music is
there any chance he comes back here
should he come back here I I don't think
so I don't know why you wouldn't uh
trust a system that you just exposed for
being completely corrupt to judge you
whether you exposing them was okay or
not why wouldn't you why well I don't
understand you know it's like why
doesn't why don't we let uh the KKK uh
why don't you go back and have them give
you a trial to see if you're really
black or not I mean what I don't that's
the craziest thing that people say why
don't you come back here and take your
Lum what are you nuts I wouldn't
do first I wouldn't even have done what
he did what he did was heroic right and
uh of course they don't want they don't
want any of the truth to come out and if
the the worst thing the only thing worse
than doing what James Clapper did is
doing what J Edward Snowden did which is
actually telling the truth right and
that's sort of when uh I don't know if
you guys saw it on CNN but Jeffrey tubin
who's consistently been uh about this
completely wrong on this and he wants uh
Snowden to come back and face the music
yet at the same time is saying that the
the things that he's revealed it's good
we know it but the guy should be in jail
telling us yes which which makes no
sense so what you agree with absolutely
I mean the the idea that that you are in
the belly of the Beast and you know all
the abuses that are happening you know
that they're spying on Americans in
violation of the Fourth Amendment you
know that there are in indefinite
detentions um you know that people are
being extraordinary rendition I mean not
that I fear that they're going to well
maybe maybe they will torture Snowden
too because look what they did to
Bradley Manning yes or he just dies in
jail yeah or you know there's a there's
an unfortunate accident whatever it may
be asking Snowden to submit himself to
all to this system that has done all of
this is freaking insane yeah it's and
it's just not true I mean bar I mean
Dian Feinstein doesn't have she doesn't
have the courage to face one tenth of
what Snowden um would be facing if he
came back to the United States yes the
people who are in charge of protecting
us like Diane Feinstein and Mike Rogers
the head of the Congressional
intelligence committee they're not
they're they're co-opted by the people
they're supposed to be regulating yeah
so I imagine the following what happened
to Snowden they'll strip him naked
they'll put him in a jail Cale they'll
deprive him of sleep put him on suicide
watch they to exactly what they did and
then and then they will destroy his
character and you know you you literally
go insane if you your sleep deprived for
too long and you know the bright lights
the cold floors whatever it may be you
know you know he has to piss himself and
himself and get have nothing to I
mean just torture and then when he goes
in understand I see he's a crazy person
yeah he's a crazy person but there to
but again let's always always remember
that the point of torture isn't to
extract information it's to get you to
say something they want you to say and
what they wanted Bradley Manning Chelsea
Manning to say was that Julian ass Sange
and him were in cahoots so they they
could go after jul
right so if Julian wasn't in cahoots
with Bradley Manning then he's just
being a journalist which is what he was
right and of course they also said that
Assange was suddenly a rapist out all
that but okay so this obviously isn't
going to go anywhere and we're going to
keep staying on it here uh but let's
move on to what a lot of people were
saying was the LIE of the year and this
whole Obamacare uh craziness uh this is
a little compilation of if you like your
plan you can keep it you can keep your
plan if you are satisfied with it if you
like the plan you have you can keep it
if you like your plan and you like your
doctor you won't have to do a thing you
keep your plan if you like your health
care plan you'll be able to keep your
health care plan if you've got health
insurance you can keep it if you like
your health care plan you will keep your
plan if you've got health insurance you
like your doctor you like your plan you
can keep your doctor you can keep your
plan if you have insurance that you
like then you will be able to keep that
insurance if you like your doctor or
healthcare plan you can keep it if you
like your healthcare plan you can keep
your healthcare plan okay so there are
many many many more examples of that
that was actually just clips from 2009
as you probably saw um all right so
we're starting with two lies here I
guess do you consider this one a lie
though because they're saying that this
isn't a lie that that's really what he
thought from the beginning no it's not a
lie and it's really stupid to equate to
two lies I mean they're nothing similar
and this is what frustrates me all the
time about the media saying well
everybody lies the left lies the right
lies well they're different kinds of
lies and this is like a marketing tactic
that went arai and it's hard to explain
a 2,000 page Obamacare Act in a quick
convenient you know radio spot or TV
spot so they went with Simplicity and
said you can keep your plan if you like
it instead of saying you can keep plan
if you like it unless one of these 18
different qualifiers come to play in
which case these 47 other things come
into play in which case another 100
things come into play and then it's it's
a muddled complicated message it's not a
big deal and should he have maybe said
it a little bit more uh I don't know
maybe he should have equivocated a bit
more and said there are you know
conditions and other terms of conditions
that might come into play right but that
just invites you know a whole new C then
they then they would spend the whole
time after he gave that speech everybody
the round table at CNN would the whole
time talking about that little thing he
said that what about those people who
can't so ex exactly so what he so it was
a technical inac Mark I think that's the
word it was a marketing Ploy he was a
Salesman selling something so I agree
it's not necessar it's not a
boldfaced absolute lie because he was
doing what he had to do to get the
things sold but shouldn't we hold him to
a slightly higher account than that no
or is it just cuz the the the dialogue
is so stupid that the CNN Round Table
would have got caught
I'm really you know what I I you know I
don't give President Obama a pass on
anything I'll give him a pass on this
because first of all the people who are
criticizing him for saying that the
reason why he had to say that was so
that he could sell that plan which the
majority of people can keep their
goddamn plans and if you lose your plan
you're going to get a better plan so
it's it's so he was lying hey I'm lying
I thought I said you're going to get one
scoop of ice cream you're going to get
two you know what I mean that's the kind
of lie he did just now right so uh I
don't think those are the same kind
those are the same kind of lies and the
people who are criticizing him the
hardest for that the reason why he had
to do this and sell this plan and give
you a plan that you might is because
that's the plan that they came up with
because they won't let us have our plan
which is Single Payer we want Single
Payer Barack Obama would implement it
except those other won't
let us have it so he has to implement
their plan he does and they still
on him right and the irony of course is
that the system was broken in the first
place and we're already paying for all
the people that go to the eer room and
and those people were losing their
health insurance anyway so we're talking
about the private Market which those
people get lose their plans all the time
every year they have to get a new plan
um yes the problem with Obamacare is is
twofold
one uh Pro Obama folks have to stop
pretending like this is some sort of
great cure all kind of Panacea like holy
now now we have Obamacare things
are be so awesome it's not true and on
the flip side the other problem is the
people who are opposed to it have to
stop pretending that this is the
apocalypse Obamacare will destroy
everyone this like it's like slavery
this like the Holocaust like it's
neither one of those things it's like a
small movement from what we had before
to a slightly better um system where now
we have previously uninsured people with
insurance and you know you can't deny
people previously uninsurable people can
now get insured right and and it's a
small marginal Improvement some marginal
downsides calm down everyone should calm
down yeah I I think that's the point
people need to hear more yeah and I
think the part that I I see slightly
different is the part about the sales
thing I'm not so sure I believe that the
ends justify the means always so in this
case in this case he was selling
something that he probably knew wasn't
exactly the truth and I get the
marketing part of it I get you had to do
it but we all sort of expected better
than better from him I guess probably 5
years ago or six years ago and now we
don't anymore I guess that's the part
that leaves me disappointed I don't see
this as a some like vicious malicious uh
lie I see this as a like a lie to get us
into a war yeah right I see this I see
this as like a bad marketing job by
people who came up with a system that's
not all that great but they're trying to
pitch it as one yeah so I I think my to
me the better lies or the lies that kind
of pissed me off uh this year were all
the the lies that John krey kept telling
about Syria and he would do it with such
indignation such righteous indignation
and if you disagree with him then you
this these are indisputable facts this
oh you son of a well I'm pretty
sure that the three of us were the most
anti-war people at tyt which in
retrospect now you know Carrie kept
saying this is Hitler asides Hitler well
now we've done nothing about Hitler so
it's oh yeah we let yeah we let Hitler
go appar that's okay if uh if he was
pitler was willing to negotiate a little
bit right then no we would have been
okay with him yeah so and by the way
let's say we were right we were right
about uh Syria then no need to go to war
in Syria no need to drop hundred million
worth of bombs in Syria and kill a bunch
of people cuz um what what's that what's
that saying there's no flag big enough
that could cover the shame of murdering
Innocents you gave me a perfect finish
on that one I can't I can't beat that
one all right let's move on to the gays
because it was a big year for the gays
and we can't do a show here without
talking about the gays uh of course prop
eight was struck down gay marriage just
in the last couple weeks passed in uh or
judicially uh has been passed now in
Ohio and in Utah uh but of course not
everything was perfect because a Duck
Dynasty yeah Phil Robertson the uh the
Granddad I guess of the Ducks well take
a
look you actually become a
food you know what you
do you suppress the truth about God by
your wickedness and you know what
happens his wrath is poured upon you
don't believe
it first they say there is no God get
him out of your mouth then they bow down
to birds animals and reptiles and each
other and the first thing you see coming
out of them
is gross sexual
immorality they will dishonor their
bodies with one another de ra each other
uh is that going on in the United States
of America is that going on Yes actually
Phil it is this is a free country we're
allowed to do with our bodies what we so
please okay so as you all know a well
A&E let me just real quick A&E suspended
him of course everyone went nuts he got
reinstated it had nothing to do with the
first amendment that is the point
because everyone kept saying first
amendment I was watching gret of an
suest on Fox News going on and on with
Rick Santorum that the first amendment
is under attack Steve can you EXP
explain why it wasn't a First Amendment
issue you're lawyer please you're a
lawyer the First Amendment prescribes
the government the government not a
private entity from preventing speech
and and there are you know time place
and manner restrictions so for example
at tyt I could I could pass a rule that
says if you say the word hamburger
you're fired that's not a that's not
first that's not an infringement of of
free speech right if I mean I could pass
a rule that says you know what if you
vote Democrat you're fired if actually
that that might be a problem okay um but
if I say but if I say uh the new rule um
if you uh if you sing you're fired
whatever it may be that's not a
violation of your freedom of uh Speech
it's not it's only when the government
comes into play so I I don't want to get
too hung up on the uh on the Free Speech
issue but isn't this exactly what
happened him being suspended at first
them making some sort of we we're a pro
LGBT company so we're going to suspend
you then the market dictated that he
came back because they realized they
were going to lose a lot of money isn't
this exactly how it should have worked
um I don't I mean I guess that's how I'm
not defending the guy obviously you know
I this think it's funny that he said
that they degrade each other with their
sex and they degrade each other is there
anything more degrading than that beard
are you kidding me look at the way you
dress do you really value yourself I
don't think so have you when was the
last time he was to a dentist I think if
he really valued himself he wouldn't be
worried about where other people are
sticking their penises and maybe he
would get cleaned up and put on nice
jacket okay so U I like your jacket
Jimmy thank you very nice and thank you
we're all cleanly shaved today very nice
thank you very much it is pretty badass
jacket and um but he but should so
that's what I said people people said to
me well why should I'm tired if someone
says something and they automatically
get fired somebody said this to me and
I'm like well first of all you have to
take them on a case-by Case basis right
so I think what Paul Adine did was much
less worse than what uh Donald Trump did
yet Donald Trump gets to keep his show
on NBC so I think you have to go Case by
case and what I'm saying about this Duck
Dynasty guy is that if you work at A&E
if you're a work like if you're a
producer or a senior producer or a
marketing guy how do you not work for
that show how do you promote that guy
who is promoting hatred against gays
with a why yeah so but isn't this how
the system should work that the market
dictated what happened I totally agree
with you Dave I think this exactly the
it worked out so A&E uh if I'm A&E if
I'm an executive I would think well this
guy said very hateful things so this
might hurt our brand this might hurt the
bottom dollar so I'm going to suspend
him and we'll figure out what we what we
should do and then there's a huge
backlash and people are like no we want
this guy I'm like okay he's back on the
air okay right it's a lot of money yeah
and look and that's what that's what
corporations are supposed to do they
need to maximize profits and if you
don't do it guess what happens you get
fired right so recently the the um the
CEO of Hyundai Motors he got replaced
placed uh even though he did a great job
for like 3 and 1 half years the last 6
months not so great gone okay that's
what happens in any any private
Corporation with respect to this
particular guy
um so a lot of people are very offended
by his comments and I find his comments
hideous actually we didn't the part that
was the worst we didn't even play that
wasn't even that I was just throwing an
extra something because we've seen all
the other yeah because the part where he
talks about like what are you going to
do Pennsylvania it's kind of SC scary
stuff and he's holding that weird like
torture like stuff in his left hand it's
all creepy and um I mean I think as far
as like anti-gay commentary and inciting
violence against gays this is as bad as
it gets that I've ever personally seen
all that being said if he has a show
Duck Dynasty on A&E and he's not saying
those things on air I don't I mean I
don't like it I don't watch the show but
I don't feel this need to go on a
crusade to get it off the air yeah 100%
I've never in any of these things Alec
Baldwin or Paul De I've never advocated
for any of them to be fired because they
can say stupid and then we can make
fun of them for it that's that's what
America is all about well by the same
token if they do get fired then it's not
like a violation of free speech they're
not going to jail yeah I mean people can
fire people all the time for it's just a
calculus that you make as as a as a TV
ex can I just make two really quick is
um I don't understand why religious
because everybody came out and defended
Duck Dynasty guy based on he's just
religious it's religion it's his what
about freedom of religion religion to
hate other people and to preach
incendiary hateful things against other
people that's what Jesus did right so
that's what they keep saying the love of
religion is always couched in hatred
it's always yeah so you can use religion
of course we know this they use religion
to justify slavery they use religion to
justify every war whever he was so they
use religion now to justify hating gays
right and persecuting gays and
marginalizing them and keeping them from
getting equal rights why is it that if
you're religious you get a pass for
being an ignorant backward
why do you why do religious oh he's he's
the bishop oh he's a so he hates gays so
that's okay but let's have more for
dinner no you you're ignorant
that's backward thinking and it's not
okay to say it's your religion then your
isn't that what the KKK could say It's
My Religion this is what Jesus they
think they're all Christian too so and
and my other thing was when Al Baldwin
you know he called the guy a
and he said that he called him a
Fathead right right because
he thought the part was the bad
part and but let me but of course he
said cuz no one says the and
then said nobody says you
fart
[Music]
snarkle you know you say you keep it
consistent with the dirtiness of the
words okay and that's going to make
another Point too look I've never
watched Duck Dynasty I don't know if
it's a good show or a bad show now if if
you are a fan of the show that's fine
you can like the show but you don't have
to like everything about that guy and
once you find out that the guy is
hateful in many ways there's no need to
worship him there's no need to run to
his defense to have these opinions I
mean I just don't that's the part that I
don't get these Fanatics who are so
angry that people are are upset by his
comments they are very upsetting
comments of course you should be upset
like OJ Simpson I was I used to be a big
fan of him until we found out he
probably most likely murdered brutally
murder two people then I'm not as much
of a fan anymore but is part it's part
of that though that we have these groups
these advocacy groups like in this case
glad and the HRC that they have to do it
like what if they don't jump on it then
what are they in business for right no
no no I think I think D I'm talking
about the fans of the show I'm talking
about the fans of the show who are so
angry that people are upset by Phil
Robertson's comments I'm like why are
you angry about that you should be angry
you should be upset by those comments
too I mean so I I I love I love you know
Sports and and I love uh I love the show
uh modern modern family if I found out
that the guy who plays Phil dumy Ty
Burell let's say I found out he's a
horrible misogynist and and talks about
raping all the time I would have
a real problem I wouldn't say well I
love Ty I love the show therefore
everything he says I'm okay with that
too I want people to separate uh the
show and the actor and all of that from
what they do in their private life and
if bad you can you can not like that
person it's not a big deal I I can I can
I can still enjoy Annie Hall even though
I find Woody Allen personally to be
reprehensible I can tell too Jewish he
too yeah a little too Jewish yeah that's
what I'm talking about also married his
daughter oh what yeah did you know that
I didn't hear that oh so he married his
Gibson didn't say anything about that
last thing on this what what do you make
of the persecuted majority we have in
the country that immediately these
people all think that they're the ones
being persecuted and it's like you know
what no gay people are actually the ones
that don't have equal rights if you're a
Christian in this country of course you
have equal rights there's nothing you
were denied as a Christian but there is
something that's not true Dave there's a
war on Christmas and Christians are
persecuted at every turn the the
atheists and the gays and the Jews they
have all the power all the power all the
power I went out I tried to buy my wife
a Christmas present the stores were all
closed so there is a war there is this
War on Christmas I want to go I want to
buy a Christmas present like no you can
buy this but not for Christmas that's
what they told me it really weird but
really what do you think about the the
idea that immediately they think they're
the ones persec it's a great psych it's
the oldest trick in the book right so
that if you watch Fox News and the
they're always the victims right and
it's just funny that the dominant
culture sees themselves as a victim
somehow to the minority culture which is
the way they've been playing it out and
it's good because it Riles up people who
don't think deeply and they gets them to
hate people they need to hate so they
can push their agenda forward I just
want to say one bring us Steve um if you
ever hear someone use a word wickedness
disregard everything that person says
that person's a clown who says the word
wickedness right can and let me just can
I say two things you got it that Duck
Dynasty guy is fighting same sex
attraction there's no doubt about it
there's no doubt about one thing that
people haven't been saying about D
there's no doubt about that guy's fight
cuz no I'm telling you if there's
anything I know for sure is that
straight guys don't give a about
what gay guys do with their penises they
don't give a it's only the guys who
think they might like it that makes them
uncomfortable that they have to go I
don't want you to be able to do that and
I think you're a horrible person and by
the way if you read up about Duck
Dynasty guy he was a Mr crazy drug
addict in the 60s and 70s so he
was this he was the exact thing he's
railing against and that's always how it
is the silence the silence Sinners
always scream the loudest so whenever I
see somebody publicly moralizing I know
that guy is doing something with his
penis that he feels bad
about good finish Jimmy all right let's
move on uh Gallup just released a poll
of their most admired people or of
American most admired people of 2013 so
of course they had to split this by sex
because if you put men and women on a
list together God only knows what would
happen uh so the most admired man uh our
President Barack Obama I thought number
two is kind of interesting George Bush
at 4% now these numbers are all pretty
low because they're just walking around
asking people who do you admire so it's
just like the same names that get popped
up uh the pope Bill Clinton Bill Gates
Clint Eastwood Ron Paul Ted Cruz Romy so
it's all over the place politically and
then let's take a look at the
women uh Hillary at 15% that's the big
one Oprah kind of down I guess the
failure of own has taken its toll on her
uh Michelle Obama Sarah Palin Ki Angela
Merkel and jelina Jolie so it's pretty
light on on celebrities like that um but
the women four women of color in that
and only one man of color in the guys I
don't know if you noticed that
interesting what do you think that means
um I think that uh I don't know I guess
white guys are cooler with dark women I
think that's that doesn't go the other
way J I know I I have it I definitely
have it oh yeah my wife's 100% Mexican
so I like the dark skin there you go
what do you feel about this admiration
list do you admire all these people is
there someone glaringly uh omitted from
that list no I I I find this list
comical and I find it comical because
it's basically uh just a list of whoever
is the most wellknown right it's it's
not really a list of people that you
admire and the fact that Sarah Palin is
on this list with 5% of the vote just
yeah just makes the whole thing useless
and uh completely lacking in any kind of
credibility whatsoever wow steo sticking
it to the gallop people that's right I
mean Sarah Palin is just a worldclass
idiot with virtually no redeeming value
whatsoever and whether you're
conservative or or Progressive there's
no reason to like her at all she is a
bumbling idiot an opportunist uh a
quitter uh she's done nothing with
herself except she's a she's a Fame
that's it why would you admire
that it's it's unbelievable so when I
was in high school high school I had the
two of the books that were assigned one
was the Brave New World by Alis Huxley
and the other one was um George Orwell
in
1984 so do these people who like uh
Sarah Palin do they not read those books
in high school do are they not assigned
those things do they not have the same
experience do they not watch Mr Smith
Goes to Washington do they not
understand how the rich and the
corporations control everything and
pervert democracy on a daily basis do
they not understand that well I think I
think if I could jump into the mind of
Sarah Palin supporter for a second I
think they see her as the fighter
against the big government of 1984 you
know they see her as this
anti-establishment
figure that's is she fighting bears and
you know doing all that Stu so they see
her as the the fighter against that I
think does that make any sense and is it
wrong St I lost Steve there zoned out
it's wrong for us to say that the people
who support her are ignorant and dumb
and they they lack the ability to
decipher and see through things right I
think you have to be ignorant and dumb
to support Sarah Palin you have to how
could you not I mean I mean and look I
don't I don't even mean that you know to
offend those out there who support Saran
I'm just saying you really need to like
open your mind read and have some
critical thinking because she is not on
your side she is on her own side she is
she's a terrible person she couldn't be
more transparent that's the thing you
can't see through a Sarah Palin then you
know I have to make a judgment call and
say you're not on the same intellectual
level that I am and uh but yet your vote
counts just as much as mine which is
wrong that's a scary that is a scary
thought yes is there anyone that you
admire that wasn't on there at all I
guess somebody that we talked about
earlier Edward Snowden probably maybe
Bradley Manning or Chelsea Manning
anyone else that's uh I would say you
know people are going to say I'm brown
noosing but I'm going to say Jen
yuger good night
everybody um well look oh well now that
you brought it up trying to get my show
back that's all I'm doing but you know
what okay look J so J and I we go really
far back so it's hard for me to see him
as a celebrity the way other people see
him him or or anything like that but he
is a very admirable admirable person
because I know intimately the sacrifices
that he's made uh Financial sacrifices
and and you know personal freedom
sacrifices that he's made to to do what
he does and to bring um you know voices
like yours and yours uh to the Forefront
and try to do something to change uh our
society for the better and our media for
the better and our democracy for the for
the better I begrudgingly admire him all
right well we're going to do a little
something about uh tyt at the end of
this whole thing but let's talk about
the reverse of tyt but there is a tea in
it the tea party uh this was a big year
for the Tea Party in a lot of scary ways
I think the sort of it culminated the
Highlight for them I think was the Ted
Cruz filibuster uh right before the
government shut down and if you forgot
it well Dr Seuss the difference with
green eggs and
ham is when Americans tried it they
discovered they did not like green eggs
and ham and they did not like Obamacare
either they did not like Obamacare in a
box with a fox in a house or with a
mouse people are frustrated because
their elected officials don't listen all
right we we are subjected to a
tremendous amount of idiocy out of
Washington mostly out of Congress was
that the stupidest moment I mean was
that just the dumbest we had the biggest
lie before with Clapper but was that
type of thing and and what then led to
the shutdown was that our dumbest
political moment because he's
like the American people tried it and
didn't like it they didn't try Obamacare
it doesn't going to affect into 2014
right um you know the website wasn't
even not working yeah that's right the
website has had yet to fail and crash
right and they they're already bashing
it so look the problem with Ted Cruz
that he's actually um I could see why
he's appealing because he says just
enough truth and that's why he's more so
much more dangerous um because he does
tap into that frustration that people
feel with their government um but he's
not the guy that's going to bring about
the change that they really want because
we all feel that the the fact is our
Representatives they don't represent us
they represent the money interest so
Cruz purports to be the guy who will
bypass the money at interest and he will
support us like the the actual people
but it's just not true and he he at best
at best he will represent the The Fringe
the extreme Fringe yeah um because the
reality is that when government works
and when it works well it does great
things for society and you know it's
like having a freeway system it's having
having the parks it's having an army
it's having FDA yeah it's having the FDA
so you don't die from eating poison uh
it's having a clean environment I mean
we need to have
cops yes firemen yeah Reg
uh yes kind of enforcing the rules so
that we all so we're all better off we
can't have Anarchy obviously and um you
know Ted Cruz Taps into that because
because we all get frustrated by the
government you know whether it's a
parking ticket or you're you you know
paying your taxes we get frustrated and
he Taps into that very effectively yeah
well he does that really well and
there's something interesting about
somebody that in a weird way the farle
and the far right should be agreeing on
certain things about money basically um
but he tapping into a whole other
paranoid delusion thing was this a good
year or bad year for the for the tea
party I think it was ultimately a bad
year for the tea party I think that well
it's the interesting thing because Ted
Cruz says uh not popular that people
don't like Obamacare people tried it
they don't like it they reject it well
let me tell you something Ted Cruz uh
Ted Cruz's approval ratings in America
are
14% obamacare's approval rating is 46%
okay so it's it's a by a factor of three
it's more popular than you are Obamacare
and that poll about Obamacare was taken
at its lowest point in the roll out so
when the big Fiasco was happening they
took that and people still liked it 46%
let me tell you something else when you
take individual parts of Obamacare and
you ask Republicans how they feel about
it overwhelmingly they like most of
Obamacare except for the individual
mandate but if they were told where that
came from they switch so that's the the
amazing thing about Ted Cruz and he's
Steve is right he's appealing because he
Taps into our frustration with
government but then he doesn't give you
a real solution what he does is you
nothing he just goes Obamacare is
up so I'm going to give you nothing to
replace it I got the best healthcare
plan in the world I got mine screw you
that's Ted Cruz well to literally give
an example of what you're saying the
government shut down cost how much 24
billion I think and it did not
accomplish anything not not a thing um
should on the left have a tea party do
you think that the Democrats actually
need a tea party to push or to pull more
left well I liked um Howard Dean when he
was running for president in 2008 and he
kept saying I'm from the Democratic wing
of the democratic party and of course
they had to shut him down right away
because he was speaking what people
really wanted to hear so I think
definitely we need more Howard Deans but
then Howard Dean then got co-opted you
know because his party won so now he's a
good Democrat so he so he shuts the
up you know made him the head of the DNC
they make him the sir they give him this
big prize at the end so uh what do you
think do do we need do the progressives
need a political movement like they have
the Tea Party yes absolutely and I think
most Americans would be on their side
yes I mean if you pull Americans on any
issue they pull way way Progressive uh
in overwhelming majorities it's just
that we don't have Representatives who
represent those interests because they
represent the interest of the moneyed
interest right so so yes if we had if we
had people like you know there there are
a few like Alan Grayson's a good guy uh
Bernie Sanders um there are there are a
few who are terrific and um their
problem is that they just don't get the
fair treatment from the media the media
treats them like they're crazy people oh
the extreme left oh they want things
like you know clean air and water and
and standards so the oil companies just
can't rape our natural resources they're
crazy like that they don't want to cut
Social Security and Medicare Steve they
don't want to cut Social Security and
Medicare the two things that don't add
to our deficit that aren't a problem
yeah um so do they need like a celebrity
then basically CU yeah there are people
I mean Bernie Sanders is obviously too
old to really become you know he doesn't
want anything bigger than what he's got
or somebody like Grayson is just sort of
back in it again but is there some is it
going to be Matt Damon or somebody like
would it take somebody like that to
really build a party it would be nice to
see a progressive caucus actually speak
with a unified voice and you know there
are enough you know there's Ron widen
there's Senator Brown there's Bernie
Sanders and yeah if they would just come
together and all keep constantly you
know that's the beauty of the right wi
is that you know George Bush even he
said it out loud he he said you know
it's a it's governing is all just about
launching propaganda you just have to
keep launching it and launching it until
it sets in and that's what the Democrats
don't do they don't have a message they
don't have a central message and I think
the progressives need to pick up the
ball and have a a message and you know
you talk about the Tea Party I think
we're the Tea Party of the Democrats you
know the Wolfpack and The Young Turks
and people like us are but we need to
somehow um influence real leadership you
know I mean we need to get them to be
more responsive to us because the
government isn't responsive I mean if
you look at the the perfect example of
that from this last year we're talking
about year end is that the the gun bill
which had 90% support in the public of
course didn't pass because what Steve
says it the moneyed interest didn't want
it to pass yeah yeah yeah look I don't
know if you have time but just real just
real quick thing I mean you know look at
our taxes I mean taxing is one of the
biggest part of what government does uh
the progressive caucus uh proposed a
progressive um um budget and what they
would do is they would tax us at at
graduated rates going all the way up
from you know from nothing to you know I
think a billion
so right now the tax rates don't make
any sense because for example if you
make above above
$250,000 you pay the same rate as a as a
multi-billionaire yeah why okay
obviously from 50,000 to 250,000 that's
a big gap but from 250,000 to to to 20
to 20 million to to 5 billion is a much
bigger Gap you should have it should be
graduated so so let's say the top margin
R 33% whatever it may be uh if you make
above a million dollar you should maybe
36% above $10 million maybe 38% above a
billion doar maybe 42% maybe even 42%
and if we did that you know you know
what would happen it would wipe out the
deficit we can fund education we could
fund you know Alternative Energy we
could do so much and why would the
conservatives and and the and the Tea
Party not be in favor of this because
it's only it's the most Fair way of
doing things stealing money from the
producers the people who are the job
creators you're stealing money from them
to give to people who are lazy that's
what they would say and I I'll tell you
this about tag you say let's raise the
income tax so billionaire but billiones
don't pay income tax M Romney proved
that so what what they so that what they
do is they pay a 15% investment tax
right so they pay capital gains taxes so
we need to get capital gains back up to
where uh but the idea behind capital
gains is if we lower the amount of money
we tax when someone invests in a
business then people will invest more
the problem is people are still going to
invest no matter how much you tax them
cuz people want to make money
I'll make 70 you're going to make 70%
return or a 60% return I'll take both
whichever one I can get I'll take 50%
return I'll take a 20% if I can invest
money and make money back that's what
we're talking about savings accounts
let's remember pay nothing anymore so
nobody talks about
that not being an incentive to save I'm
with you so only save if I get
75% 60% I'm not going to say but doesn't
this go to to the messaging problem
because
the the 1% we all talk about the 1% and
it's a great number it's like if you
like your plan you keep it it's just a
simple thing but really the 1% we did a
thing on it a couple weeks ago it's
something like
$250,000 you're the 1% but you can have
$250,000 and really not be rolling in a
ton you know and living a nice decent
middle upper class life but so it's not
about that we should have a progressive
tax that really when you're talking
about millions of dollars and hundreds
of millions dollars and then ultimately
the billions of dollars so that the
Walmart family doesn't own as much as
the bottom 4 well the estate tax used to
take care of all that at the end so then
when you died okay you got to have all
your money for your whole life and then
when you died we took half your money
and then cuz you know you got to benefit
from living in this country and this
society that we built now we you have to
pay for it after you're dead but then
they stopped doing that because they had
it's around 5 million something they had
a vote to see who had to pay taxes dead
people dead millionaires or living
people and guess who won dead
millionaires that's how powerful money
is wow that's good yeah it's true and
and it's ridiculous because um it's not
really the top 1% that's the problem
it's a top .1% because if you're the top
1% your interests are much pretty much
align with most people in the 98%
because my analogy is this if you're if
you're making $250,000 a year that you
know what that means that means you're
going afford to eat the nice steak if
you're making 50,000 a year you get to
eat a burger okay if you're making less
you to maybe get a hot or whatever it
may be but if you're making 20 million a
year you own the whole restaurant and
the entire city block okay so it's a
it's a it's a game changer it's a
totally different level when you're
making millions and millions of dollars
I mean this 250s I
mean it's a Hunger Games it's it's like
the the the Uber Rich making the people
who make $250,000 fight with people who
make $50,000 okay that that's a silly
fight right it's the wrong fight but on
that note hot dogs's on me after the
show can I can I can I give you you a
final thought on this and
um uh before 1980 uh the upper uh
5% had accumulated $40 trillion which is
a lot of money $40 trillion since then
the upper 5% have accumulated more money
than the entire human race had produced
prior to
1980 think about that stat that's a big
stat and that comes from David Stockman
Ronald Reagan's budget director right so
a segment on tea party basically we
ended with uh progressive tax look it up
all right final part of our year in
review I want to talk to these guys
about whether this was a good year or a
bad year for the US for the world for
The Young Turks for us personally
America had a very up and down year I
think between the NSA and drones and
everything with Obamacare and all that
stuff does this a net gain or a net loss
for America was this a good year for
America um now I sound like a cable news
person that we would make fun of with
these stupid b but what do you think the
the the heart of it I'm going to say
that there's a lot lot of disparaging
things or dis dispiriting I don't know
that's dispiriting or discouraging
discouraging things that happened this
year but there's also good things I mean
I think Edward Snowden is a positive I
think Chelsea Manning is a positive
thing that there's still this I mean
those are true Americans as far as I'm
concern and then The Young Turks raise
over $400,000 which just goes to for
their new studio which just goes to show
you that there's people out there who
care yeah well we're going to get to The
Young Turks in a second but uh the
bigger than The Young Turks America
America was a good year or a bad year
for America America I think was a bad
year uh and the reason why I think it's
a bad year is that
um We are continuing on the same path
that we were on last year and the year
before and every year since 1980
basically which is that there is greater
and greater wealth inequality uh the
income gap is getting worse and worse
and the and the gap between those who
have everything and those who have so
precious few is just getting worse and
nothing has happened in 2013 in my mind
to derail that process in any way yeah
um I mean this whole citizens of United
thing has been Juiced up you know more
and more and uh and our Supreme Court
seems just as corporate just as Pro
corporate as any other part of our
government now and um I think America is
losing its way and I've said this many
times before like America to me is more
than just the physical place it's an
idea it's an idea that we have equal
opportunity we have these certain in
rights and those rights are disappearing
I mean you know the fourth amendment is
pretty much gone um
and I don't it saddens me uh I wish we
could you know put on the breaks and
reverse our trajectory because I think
if we continue this path it's going to
be just worse yeah well I think you're
particularly hitting on about you know
we're we're a nation of immigrants and
everyone wanted to come here and I
wonder if I if I was an immigrant now or
an immigrant family from anywhere from
from Latin America would you feel that
this is the where you
can so they've already done studies
that's proven that the we now have less
economic mobility in the United States
than in other Western democracies so
it's going the exactly what Steve said
it's going the opposite way and why does
income inequality matter Jimmy because
if they've I've also studied this and
they find out that the societies that
are the most unequal inside their
societies suffer from the most societal
ills they suffer from more crime or uh
uh um more out of out of wedlock BS
every bad thing that comes with it it's
it's it's not about the wealth of the
society but the inequality inside of it
and that goes for the United States and
every other uh country too yeah so what
about for the world Good Year bad year I
mean the main thing I guess is Syria has
been just locked in a civil war that
literally hundreds of thousands of
people have been killed we we didn't do
anything and it's and it's still going
on um and then there's all now there's
some there's stuff going down in Africa
right now I mean for the world did did
did the cause of freedom and equality
and all that kind of stuff move in a
good direction overall you
think oh wow for Humanity I'm giving you
a big one Humanity um I'm going to give
you a bit kind of kind of a copout
answer I suppose I think it's I'm going
to say good for the world in the sense
that uh I do believe that the Arc of uh
history bends towards Justice um I think
Martin Luther King is correct um if you
take any particular segment of it it may
be a bad bad period so 2013 alone is it
a good period or a bad period for the
world I don't know but I'm going to say
good just because I think things are
overall trending in the right direction
in terms of more equality um and and
justice for more people
um it's a generic answer I can he's
trying to be positive for new I
appreciate that what do you got well
hopefully we've hit a Tipping Point you
know hopefully you know Occupy Wall
Street happen they crushed them
uh but there's people now there's the
pope right and so that's a big deal I
think the Pope I can't believe that I'm
really happy that we have a pope right
that because I'm so anti everything
about the pope but at least he is he is
has an a a message of economic equality
you know and that this that capitalism
that that there's brutalities involved
in a capitalistic society that we need
to guard against that we're not doing
anymore and the and the so I think
that's a good thing for
the world in general I think the
pope of all the leaders you know the
pope is going to be the guy who will
make up the biggest difference going
forward in the next decade I think in
the world and now you know the pope
starts talking about that stuff next
thing you know Barack Obama starts
talking about income inequality two days
later yeah all of a sudden he's talking
about yeah you know I guess he's right
so I think that's what has to happen you
have to CH and we have to call out these
phony Christians right brush limbo he's
anti- Catholic suddenly the Pope's not a
Catholic C Pope's not he brush Limar
knows more about Christianity than the
pope apparently so yeah so we need to
call out these phony Christians who have
turned Jesus into a mascot of America
who hates the poor hates the gays and
protects rich people that's third Jesus
and of course the pope is telling you
that's not and that's not the way we
should go and there are brutalities to
capitalism that we have to look at yeah
I think and we haven't looked at them
because the theory behind capitalism
that the right proposes or the Iran
people they say well you have the
opportunity we want everyone to have the
opportunity if was born poor I would
work really hard get an education and I
would move upward and if I didn't work
hard I didn't deserve to be well they
don't ever look at the facts though the
what is the outcome of your Society well
the fact that most people don't reach
the upper levels don't move up well
that's their problem so they so they
don't care about really what happens in
practicality they only car about they
only care about theories which is what
Ein ran people are all about theories
this purest idea of how the world should
be but it's not how it is but those
books were so thick they just look they
know what they're saying all right so
away from the world for The Young Turks
Good Year bad year I mean from where I'm
sitting this was a pretty great year and
you hit on it uh we raised a lot of
money that was crowdfunded by the people
who watch what we do and care about what
we do so I I think this would you say
this was a changing year for The Young
Turks yeah 2013 was a very very good
year uh for The Young Turks primarily
the sense that we we've kind of became a
bigger company in the sense that you
know like you guys are much more
integral parts of uh of The Young Turks
before 2013 Jimmy would come on every
now and then but but not in a systematic
way um and we've kind of gotten our
independence from current TV where we
were very much wrapped up in in um in
the TV show um and there's a lot of
misconceptions out there um you know
alore never funded this company or or or
had any big role here jent simply had a
show on current TV right but that show
took up a lot of our time and our
resources we didn't get paid uh for Jen
being on the show Jen got paid um so um
that so getting that off uh off our
plate and being able to focus on growing
our company uh as an independent
Enterprise you know bringing on more
Talent creating more shows and you know
having a bigger following having a
louder voice has all been very good but
I will say that 2014 looks to be
a transformational year for The Young
Turks so I'm really looking forward to
that well listen I've only been here for
it's been 9 months it seems like I've
been here for a lot longer than that but
it's been pretty great and my final
question to you guys because people like
when you get personal for steo Good Year
bad year give me a highlight now I'm
putting you on the spot yeah 2013 was a
great year for me um look I I I don't
believe in a God but I do thank my
blessings um you know for first of all I
have a great family I have I have
amazing friends I have a job that I love
and I get to work with great people
every single day um I still am healthy
and can play sports um not quite at the
level that I would like to play but
close enough I'm happy with it um and uh
yeah my kids are growing up and uh
there's been a lot of positive changes
in their in their lives and uh it's been
a very very good year uh but to be
honest I think every year has been a
great year so wow I'm giving you two
this is tough this is like when the
comedian kills and then you got to go on
right after and bring it bring it Jimmy
door well I have to say my life has been
even better than Steve's um I also lived
with his family and his kids really
admire me and we have a good time
together no
uh I know I don't know if this sounds
sincere but it's true that I would say
2013 probably my best year of my life uh
I just happy year uh working with The
Young Turks has uh you know been a great
experience it's it's in it's really you
know it's exciting it's interesting it's
I found something I like to do as much
as standup which I never thought I would
and I love doing this and um I sold a
book this year and uh so yeah made a lot
of great new friends kind I feel like uh
it's been I went off to Propecia that's
been your big and I got to tell you it
has cuz it kills your libido right so
when you when you go on propa it kills
your libido but when you go off mine
came back tfold and I'm not I tell
people I'm back to my wife I'm
crazy about
it I I buy I buy a lingerie and stuff
now and we look forward to it and I'm
just like this is it's like we just
started dating again so good year for
Jimmy bad year for Jimmy's wife
yeah I would just like to say
specifically to Phil robertsson that I
asked a straight guy about his good year
bad year he made it about his penis not
the gay guy and finally I'll say this
was a great year I'm happy I'm healthy
I'm doing work that I love with people
that I love and I think we're doing
something good here and uh that's it we
will see you next year 2014 is going to
be a big one people stick with us we got
plenty
[Music]
more